you know your stuff sorting hat and you
never make a mistake so that means that
despite their bad intentions dark
wizards like cornea squirrel and Peter
Pettigrew just didn't belong in
Slytherin a lot of people consider
slytherins evil but we think that
forests like horn Regulus black and
severus snape would begs to differ
we're about to give you your biggest
challenge yet sorting hat we've got a
dozen Disney villains that need to be
sorted are you up for the challenge
sure most evil wizards hail from this
Lutheran house but that doesn't mean
that every ill-intentioned person
automatically gets a set of green in
silver robe in fact most of our beloved
Disney villains don't belong in this
house keep watching to find out which
terrifying villain has a trueborn
Hufflepuff heart Hades let's kick things
off with Hades the god of the underworld
at first glance we might mistake Hades
as a natural-born Slytherin after all he
is very cunning vengeful and
power-hungry who once you dig a little
deeper you find out that Hades is a
Ravenclaw through and through
Hades is smart original and super witty
everything he says packs a punch and he
looks great in blue next up is Cruella
De Vil the Wicked antagonist of Disney's
101 Dalmatians
Corella might enjoy sporting the color
red but back in Hogwarts her wardrobe
was filled to the brim with green and
silver roads her ella is 100% Slytherin
she's cunning and ambitious but most of
all Cruella is resourceful in the
evilest way she has a me first attitude
and she keeps her eyes on the prize no
matter what Captain Hook now this one
probably won't surprise you Captain Hook
is a Hufflepuff the captain of the Jolly
Roger might have a bone to pick with
Peter Pan but that's only because Peter
chopped his hand off turning him into
Captain Hook in the first place hook and
his first mate mr. Smee totally belong
in Hufflepuff hook might be hot-tempered
and arrogant but he's also
this tolerant and beyond dedicated just
like the average shuffle there's only
one more Hufflepuff on our list keep
watching to find out who it is and then
there's scar the lion who was so busy
making moves he sacrificed his family
values to get to the top Skaar has his
own best interests at heart he's
manipulative and selfish gets smart and
charismatic there are no buts about it
Skaar is a Slytherin mother Gothel but
Agatha will go down in Disney history as
one of the most manipulative villains of
all time she convinced Rapunzel that she
was her mother and pieced together an
elaborate lie to keep her locked up in a
tower
mother Gothel is a ravenclaw she uses
her intelligence and wit to trick people
into helping her and get what she wants
Gothel is quick on her feet and sharp as
a tack Gaston
it's not right for a woman to read soon
she starts getting ideas believe it or
not but Gaston is a Gryffindor in fact
he's the only Disney villain who falls
under this category
Gaston might have his priorities in a
bunch but he's brave determined and
daring he also has an affinity for
scarlet and gold everyone was scared to
face the Beast
except for Gaston he might have been a
villain but he saw himself as a hero in
his own right
Ursula next up is Ursula the wicked sea
witch who is known for being a ruthless
ruler who will stop at nothing to get
what she wants she's power-hungry
two-faced and persuasive making her the
perfect Slytherin Marcella belongs down
in the dungeons with a bloody baron just
like a true Slytherin Ursula is
self-preserving cunning and ambitious
the Evil Queen queen grimhilde might
have the components of a Slytherin but
at the end of the day she's a textbook
Ravenclaw the Evil Queen crave stability
and high status which is why she has
devised a plan to take over snow ice
kingdom she's an actress in her own
right and she's smart enough to devise a
plan that gets her where she wants to be
she knows how to read people and she's
not afraid to make career
Jaffar I think she took it rather well
Jabbar used to be the Royal vizier of
Agrabah but he didn't get that position
by being honest
he used his cunning personality to
brainwash the Sultan and would have
succeeded in taking over Agrabah if it
hadn't been for Aladdin and his friends
Jafar walks the walk and talks the talk
of an ambitious Slytherin he even has a
serpent staff yzma it is no concern of
mine whether your family has just like
Jafar use my used to be a royal advisor
but unlike Jafar yzma wouldn't get
sorted into this alluring house yzma is
a ravenclaw despite her bad reputation
she had good intentions for stealing
Emperor Kuzco throne he may be sarcastic
and power-hungry but she was smart
enough to convince prong to do her evil
bidding for her unfortunately for yzma
Krunk wasn't smart or evil enough to get
the job done
yzma should have known better than
putting her trust in a good-hearted
Hufflepuff Shan you how many men does it
take to deliver a message the sorting
hat would only need to hover over
SHINee's head for a milliseconds before
belting out Slytherin Shan Yu is as evil
as they come he would give Lord
Voldemort's a run for his galleons
Maleficent and last but not least is the
wicked evil fairy Maleficent she might
come across as a Slytherin but beneath
her stone-cold exterior lies the heart
of a true born hufflepuff everything
maleficence does she does because of her
broken heart slytherins don't get
offended when they aren't invited to
christenings but hufflepuffs sure do
which Disney villain do you share a
Hogwarts house with tell us in the
comments and that's a wrap give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things thanks for
watching we'll see you again soon